watch out for cannibals and bad acting
oh my god because we have the worst show
ever about people stuck on an island and
I've seen the ending of lost Netflix as
the island is the worst thing to happen
to an island since fire festival
currently sitting at 3.8 on IMDB which
is just slightly higher than my uber
rating so you know I had to take one for
the team and watch this train wreck the
show begins with this woman chase washed
upon the shore of a deserted island it's
only a matter of time before she meets
Blue Crush and instead of them being
like hey oh my god what happened are you
okay she immediately gets a knife pulled
on her every character being an absolute
[ __ ] for no reason when they should
be working together to I don't know
survive is a common occurrence on this
show altogether there are 10 castaways
who immediately get to work at finding
food and building shelter oh they don't
[Music]
or you could be like Taylor over here
and decide to tan at least when Shannon
did it on loss she thought a rescue team
would be hours away here these guys have
no idea where they are how they got
there and their first priority is to
have some fun it's insane I should also
mention that this show throws in
completely useless red herrings under
the guise that it may be integral to the
plot later on like this book Taylor digs
up on the beach Jules Verne's the
mysterious island you think that would
come into play later on but nope it's
useless no idea why it's there so
chasing this guy Brody decide to
actually be smart and look for water and
they stumble across this waterfall and
let me just tell you guys this scene is
a masterclass of perfection first of all
Brody suggests that the two of them
don't tell the others about the water
maybe we should
secondly you think the others won't be
able to find this huge-ass waterfall
that clearly is just a few minutes from
the beach now listen to this I'm sorry
but you can't just get rid of the food
problem by pointing into the jungle and
saying yeah and food is there some
magical food factory you didn't show us
the problem of food is one of the most
important things to figure out when
stranded on an island and the writers
here just blow it off with a throwaway
line we'll get to this a bit later with
the origins of the mysterious bananas
and for no reason brody tries to hold on
guys I can't use the r-word my last
video which used it got demonetised I'm
not bitter about it anyway let's just
say Brody tries to hmm violate chase are
you [ __ ] kidding me because you know
the first thing you want to do when
you're stranded on an island is to
violate someone so back on the beach
these idiots are swimming instead of
making a shelter or being in any way
productive when they're attacked by
sharks because of course so one of the
castaways Donovan is eaten and they all
just kind of go back with their lives
Brody tries to justify his actions what
though and he returns to the beach with
some items by himself and Blue Crush is
like where'd you get all that stuff you
know you just tried violating her two
seconds ago
now you're white knighting oh and
remember how he was like let's not tell
the others about the water
this is him now I just I think it's
better if we work together as a team
okay okay
chase arrives back at the beach and
beats the [ __ ] out of Brody before
storming off and finding Donovan's shark
bitten body on the beach he's still
alive and they bring him back and then
there's this insanely confusing
explanation that each of their bodies
when they washed up on shore was
thirty-nine steps apart from one another
and if you multiply that by 10 you get
the distance to someplace on the island
they didn't to go to it doesn't make any
sense but the writers just thought it
was cool to throw the number 39
everywhere
because apparently it's the average
number of steps from a jail cell to the
electric chair oh yeah everyone here is
a prisoner on death row and this is just
a simulation spoiler alert so get this
all the castaways decide to leave the
guy dying from the shark bite to go on
this stupid quest which just ends up
leading them to a sign that doesn't
really help the plot at all like one of
them couldn't stay back to make sure he
was okay chase is frustrated that no one
believes her that something weird is
happening on this island and when she's
by herself she finds an emergency raft
floating out in the ocean so she goes to
retrieve it and uh-oh cuts her foot so
this idiot knowing a dude was just
bitten by a shark a few hours ago
decides to swim after the raft with this
open bleeding wound a weed that stupid
on the island Blue Crush decides to hook
up with Brody the guy she was just
warned sexual assaults people cuz okay
and how the [ __ ] did this girl get a
banana like look at that thing it's
perfect should be in some Delmont a
commercial chase tries to open one of
the locked boxes from the raft and God
knows how she figured out the
combination inside is a gun at oh they
will never find it hidden under this
palm branch more bananas and this girl
is making cute hats Brody is found
murdered on the beach and guess who gets
the blame
she's knocked unconscious and wakes up
in a futuristic prison facility in Texas
where we find out that she's part of a
simulation to see if death row inmates
can be rehabilitated we meet this
absolute caricature of a prison warden
who is so over-the-top it's hard to take
him seriously don't get up oh thank you
thank you chases return to be put back
in the simulation she's able to escape
beat the crap out of several guards and
the warden isn't even reprimanded for
this
so even though she's violent and later
tries to throw a chair at the jury
responsible for seeing if she's a good
candidate to be rehabilitated they let
her back in the program anyway she's
taken into a truck to be sent back and
the guard just randomly decides to
attack her by the way in the previous
scene we've seen her take out four train
guards by herself but here there's only
one dude watching her and she's not even
restrained what jail are these guys
running obviously she gets away only to
find herself in this pod room where her
and the others are being held for the
simulation and she gets caught back on
the island the others explained that she
was only gone for ten minutes but in the
real world she was gone for hours this
is kind of weird since later on we see
shots of the guards live-streaming
what's going on there but how can they
do that if time is so distorted the
castaways are introduced to Bonnie and
Clyde yes those are their real names who
are basically rogue u.s. marshals under
the command of warden wells to stir [ __ ]
up in the simulation honestly I'm still
not sure what the point of these
characters were really but they tell the
castaways to find the village on the
other end of the island which in
retrospect plays no significant role in
the plot Clyde kills one of the
castaways Hayden who we see have a
flashback of her killing this guy and
crossing his name off a list it's
explained later on in a throwaway line
that Hayden was on death row because she
was a vigilante killer who killed men
who abused women and heavily implied
that she was the one who killed Brody
after he abused Blue Crush is it all
making sense now of course it is I guess
this is a good time to highlight how
every character on the island had their
memories erased but yet the characters
still know certain things that are
convenient for the writers like Blair
who was a nurse in real life is able to
help Donovan even though she wouldn't
remember that she was a nurse speaking
of Blair she was on death row for
assisting in euthanasia and when she
talks to the doctor about one of the
patients filing a do not resuscitate
this happens she told me she fell did do
not resuscitate
well we don't have it on file she
doesn't want to live anymore that's
really not our problem with the
paperwork got lost um I'm pretty sure it
is
you're the hospital no back at the beach
Donovan is running [ __ ] you just got
bit by a shark
Taylor has had enough and steals the
emergency RAF to leave the island on her
own apparently without any food or water
because everyone on this show is a dumb
idiot chase does some investigating in a
run-down resort they actually found in
episode 2 yet none of them have decided
to make this their shelter yet and
learns that her and Cooper used to be
boyfriend/girlfriend in real life I have
no idea how Taylor got on this rock but
okay let's go with it
and hosh it she ain't doing so hot but
she seems to be enjoying it it's here we
get some insight into blue crushes
character and wait is that the guy from
workaholics you know how this is gonna
feel coming out feast probably not good
it's gonna make our buttholes bleed it's
actually her husband who straight-up
attacks her in front of her children she
ends up cheating on him and when he
finds out about it says she'll never see
her children again
so what does she do kill them Bonnie and
Clyde have reinstated everyone's
memories somehow and Donovan suddenly
becomes obsessed with Blair this place
is [ __ ] awesome you just got bit by a
shark apparently in his previous life
Donovan was an in cell not a good time
can I at least give you my flowers no
I'm married they're almost as pretty as
you tonight
so Mason uses the only flair they have
to draw Donovan's attention away from
Blair why the [ __ ] did you fire that
flare gun deaths don't you've only got
one flare but when Blair later uses the
same gun to defend herself from Donovan
it magically has another bullet also
everyone in this damn show is so bad at
hiding [ __ ] cool rack focus to a skull
where Taylor has found a bowl that says
chicken soup now I don't know about you
guys but when I find a random bowl of
chicken soup I drink that [ __ ] Bonnie
and Clyde show up no idea how they also
got to this island and they're about to
kill Taylor when she says this line
talk to your manager breath anyways they
decide to let the cannibal on the island
eat her we don't even get to see the
cannibal I wish I saw the cannibal
that'd be freaking cool anyways it was
the cannibal who provided her with that
soup but it wasn't chicken it was her
fingers yeah she didn't realize her
fingers were missing Blue Crush wakes up
to find the village burning and is
haunted by the ghosts of her children
who she says she misses every day well
maybe you shouldn't have killed them
then jay says a flashback to when she
met Cooper in the Marines Cooper asked
her out in the middle of a mission which
leads to this Cooper has his face half
burned but for some reason it's not
burned in the simulation Blue Crush who
stabbed herself in the real world still
has her stab wound in the simulation
why doesn't Cooper have his burns oh
that's right because the writers thought
it would be a cool reveal later on in
the season gotcha
we learned that Cooper killed chases
overbearing mother after she wouldn't
give them any money but the thing I like
about this flashback scene is that she's
enjoying a nice glass of wine in her
mansion in a dimly lit basement with a
gun this flashback gives Cooper some
sort of PTSD and he accidentally kills
Moses when he snaps out of it but the
only thing he can think of is
remembering that he killed chases mom
Moses hello there's a dying man here you
just shot there attacked by Bonnie and
Clyde where chase manages to kill Bonnie
but here's the weird thing in episode 3
the warden tells us that if you die in
the simulation you die in real life but
we see Bonnie alive and well in the last
episode there's no logical consistency
in this show chase is stabbed but is
taken out of the simulation just in time
where she awakens back in the prison the
jury heard Cooper's confession of
murdering her mother a crime she was on
death row for so now she's free to go
but the sheriff's job is in jeopardy
because he was sabotaging the program a
sabotage which resulted in the deaths of
several of the inmates before chase can
go she attends this pointless scene with
a therapist or lawyer I don't know what
she is but she tells chase the point of
the simulation is to see if the inmates
can achieve Redemption but then she goes
on to say that they don't know what that
looks
like yet so let me get this straight you
put people on an island subject them to
torture and you don't even know when
they're supposedly cured or not what
could go wrong the warden convinces the
nurse to commit murder by lethally
injecting chase I guess her job is more
important than living with the guilt of
killing someone but the warden is so
stupid he forgets his own prison has
security cameras in it and he's caught
by dr. vise one of the jury members and
later sent to the island as punishment
for his crimes we find out that Chase is
actually an old woman god this show and
for some reason the inmates are put into
the simulation looking like the age when
they committed the crime it's just a
simulation I guess that makes sense
because who would watch a show about a
bunch of grandmas on an island killing
each other actually that show sounds
infinitely better than this one one of
the more hilarious aspects of the show
is how the writers try to justify this
program being funded by the US
government apparently in the future
global warming has gotten so bad that
the water levels have risen causing
massive crime waves so the government
now has so many criminals that needs to
redeem them so many more people are
criminals now since the water started
taking the land that we have to have a
way to redeem people here's a solution
how about not spending billions of
dollars on a simulation for 10 death row
inmates and put it towards say renewable
energy levies really cool hats dr. Weiss
says that Chase will have about an hour
before she sees herself in her true form
and she's thrust out into the real world
we get this shot of the real world with
flying cars and giant skyscrapers yet
all the technology items and clothing on
the island look like they're from 2019
let's also remind ourselves that the
last episode has almost no action in it
it's basically scene after scene of
people talking in chairs
the final episode should be the climax
it should be where all the build-up from
the previous episodes come to a head yet
the island achieves none of that it ends
in the equivalent of a wet fart with bad
acting dialogue potholes and an entire
cast of unlikable characters the island
solidifies itself as the worst show on
Netflix it pisses me off to no end that
shows like the Oh a get cancelled yet
trash like this gets funding with new
platforms like Disney Plus and
plus dropping in the next few months
Netflix will no longer be the only game
in town so you better shape up Netflix
I'd hate for my ex-girlfriends account
I'm still secretly using for free to be
shut down due to shitty content also
bring back the yo a thank you for
watching everyone make sure to give the
video a like and subscribe with the bell
on I always have new content on the way
if you happen to see this travesty of a
show please comment below with your
thoughts you can also follow me on
twitter at things story whitey and until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much
[Music]